Alfredo canziani is an assistant teacher
professor of computer science at nyu's
current Institute of mathematical
Sciences where he works under the
tutelage of deep learning Pioneer Jan
lacun
his current interests include model
predictive policy learning visual
temporal representations and
self-supervised visual representation
learning as well as the development of
deep neural network models for practical
applications
his multiple Publications include a
thesis on cortexnet a robust predictive
deep neural network trained on videos
Alfredo has a wide variety of hobbies
including music mathematics cooking and
dancing anyone interested in Yan's
groundbreaking Concepts on joint
embedding prediction architectures and
non-contractive self-supervised learning
or energy-based models should also check
out his YouTube channel where he's
uploaded an entire lecture series on
energy-based models with the Anne lacoon
himself
in fact Alfredo is in the process of
writing a book on energy-based models
and is planning on publishing it in two
different formats one for print and one
for screen
in addition Alfredo has published a
paper titled teaching deep learning a
boisterous ever evolving field in 2021
in which he recounted his time spent in
the classroom teaching this complex and
rapidly evolving discipline
he's also created best practices for
instructing in this fast developing area
such as dividing the course into
introductory and intermediate sections
and breaking down the information into
two-week units with a common theme
Alfredo suggests setting up three days
to develop a single course which
includes time for reading the relevant
literature implementing the relevant
numerical methods and making the
necessary slides
to ensure the success of a remote
lecture Alfredo suggests setting up some
kind of feedback loop between the
instructor and the audience he also
recommends choosing dark solid colors to
draw attention to composition and
investing in audio and lighting
equipment and also utilizing video
editing software to export the finished
product in high definition
he also Advocates filming scientific
lectures employing automated captioning
and including a table of contents to
make the video searchable emphasizing
the significance of accessibility and
inclusiveness in the classroom and being
a startup founder myself in
accessibility Tech and that's two big
thumbs up from me
so as a multi-talented expert in
artificial intelligence and computer
science Alfredo has made significant
contributions to the field he enjoys
sharing his knowledge with others and he
thrives on the challenge of inventing
new things and pushing the boundaries
his writings and research have been very
influential and they've raised the bar
for Education and Training in this field
anyway I hope you enjoyed this
conversation we recorded it live at new
rips a couple of weeks ago cheers
Alfredo hey hi it's a pleasure to meet
you I've been a huge fan for so long
well and I was hoping I'd bump into you
in Europe's eventually you did
eventually I did I did
um how's the conference for you pretty
fun finally we are back in person I miss
it so much right especially running
through all posters I checked each and
every of them right and I complain about
the one that I don't like
when I was I saw your complaint about
the accessibility on David Chalmers
I mean come on you have three things
right you have a camera stream you have
the slides and the subtitles taking
different parts of the thing and I can't
see [ __ ] right
come on
yeah
I mean we're supposed to be accessible
right I cannot see what's going on I'm
like from here whatever right I know
anyway um I agree with you by the way so
so the poster sessions it's overwhelming
because there are so many things going
on and so many people two hours one
thousand posters well four hours two
thousand yeah it's a lot yeah but still
I think this is one thousand times
better than the gather town because here
I can just walk through the whole thing
and I get a first glimpse of what's
going on yeah and actually can pitch I
can ask like a 20 seconds uh piece of
their thoughts right on their posters
while on the gander town
so um Alfredo what are you most excited
about
I guess being in person going to parties
maybe yeah uh needing perhaps students
actually you know all the things I've
been doing for the course it's
everything is free and the only thing
that comes back is appreciation yeah
blood since we were not in person I
wasn't kind of getting much of this
appreciation so it's like my heart is
like
crazy and now it's like
I love it right that's one of maybe all
the reasons that he keeps helping like
keeps pushing me forward right the
appreciation I think it's like a major
component exactly now your best uh line
for you know let's say energy-based
models and the self-supervised learning
and stuff like that but I mean is there
anything else that's like really top of
mind for you in Nai at the moment
so actually those are actually Young's
things that I helped him uh communicate
to people that are not experts right so
Jan is amazing but he's using yeah he
can communicate very well with experts I
think I help him reach a different type
of uh people right like for your
beginner you might have some issues you
know with not knowing exactly everything
Jan is talking about just quite yet so I
try to fill in those gaps such that it
becomes more accessible right and I
think it's I mean I I think it's a kind
of valuable
contribution because again I I think
those things are not necessarily
complicated it's just different right so
but then if you don't have all the
prerequisite knowledge then you might
face some difficulties in appreciating
all those things right so I try to
provide that
the things I'm actually interested about
is this uh graphical language
representation of neural diagram which
is using some sort of electrical
engineering type of drawings right the
electrical engineer myself we represent
circuits with transistors and condensed
capacitors resistors inductors and all
those things right maybe I repeated
twice resistors resistor capacitor
inductor transistors and diodes and all
those things right each of those
components are characterized by a
specific law right physical law
similarly in our field we should be able
to agree on a common representation
which is not math to represent
connections right which those are
diagrams of neural networks right we
should all as a community come up with
something that we are not seemingly able
to do that so I'm trying to with this
textbook I'm writing
to provide a energy perspective of deep
learning through diagrams which use
colors
so that's the thing I'm working right
now and it's been taking a lot of effort
but I think it's
pretty and
clear and allows you to really
understand how things work without
unnecessary complications using like
probabilistic Frameworks and all those
that are
additional like uh obfuscations and uh
you know it it doesn't have to be
complicated to be useful and pretty
right actually to me the simplest the
simpler it is the prettier it is right
if I try to explain to you something I
will try not to hide it right I want you
to understand that [ __ ] I'm talking
about right so I will try to be the less
even the less you know uh what's called
like um
you can call it whatever you want but
it's basically that I think I mean for
folks that don't know Alfredo he is the
king of visualization because I think a
lot of what you're talking about there
in also in in spirit with Yan's
energy-based models because he has this
kind of pictorial formalism for helping
people understand what is something
similar to like a probabilistic
graphical model and and I think it's a
really it's a it's a bit of an opener
actually because it helps people it
makes intelligible something that would
be inaccessible to so many people and I
don't think you necessarily need all
these you know
extra thing to do other stuff like I I
understand you know a lot but you don't
have to use it because you just know it
right if you can do the same thing but
in an easier way I think it's an
improvement right and I know you know
much more but
well too bad I mean you're gonna be you
just take that knowledge for yourself
you don't have to necessarily use that
you know overly complicated formulation
to talk about easy things right ideas
are supposed to be simple right then you
can you know
uh he was like it's like okay hold on
the thing is that you have a picture in
your mind you have some concept then in
order to communicate that image to
someone else you convert it to some sort
of formalism which is very obscure and
cryptic you're writing a paper and a
more cryptic the nicer I think you might
feel because of it you know inaccessible
and then you send it out other people
have to really read this crap and figure
out what is the mental picture they have
to have in order to understand the
mathematical upside down you've written
and then finally they got it but that's
a picture right so why the fact they
want to do this conversion with this OBS
obfuscation right yeah horrible that is
symbolic mathematics too to the core
because mathematicians they they create
abstractions to kind of
um represent their knowledge but it's
after the fact that's putting the cart
before the horse actually most people
from first principles don't think that
way but I think I think it's easy to
delude yourself when you understand
something that other people would think
in that way anyway um Alfredo so nice to
meet you where can people find out your
textbook and more information about you
right so there is my first tweet that is
um what's called uh ethiopian's Twitter
so it's it's giving some context of
what's going on with the books because I
got a few
um pushbacks I think when I start
working on the sparse coding I wasn't
smart enough to make it work so it took
me some effort to get it but then okay
if you go on my website which is going
to be at call Dot get
github.io is it called like that the
GitHub pages I think so we'll put it
we'll put a link up in the
um and then you find everything there
you have you find my didactics like the
teaching stuff you find all the links
are that are necessary like every find
everything over there right so all the
uh also there is a blog post about eigen
directions which is pretty nice and I
don't think enough people know about
America we should advertise that as well
okay thank you so much great to meet you